you may spend a lot of your time writing  code i certainly do  with every keystroke you and i are  creating future liability  the code we write has to be tested  deployed debugged maintained stored and  one day retired that's expensive what we  really want is to process business data  code is just a way to get there but  there are other ways  here's how i reduce the amount of code i  have to write  one i use cloudrun to go serverless  instead of mucking about with servers  two i use google cloud workflows to  orchestrate my services with simple yaml  instead of with code  three i let my users enter and view data  in google sheets instead of building  custom interfaces  four i use google data studio to create  dashboards instead of building them with  code  five i use appsheet to create data  centric apps with zero code  what's your favorite way to reduce code  let me know in the comments